are you with Shin Megami Tensei fan well  you might get to play some new SMT games  on your Nintendo devices before too long  I'm Tony and this is your handheld  GameSpot news update Atlas is bringing  new SMT games to both Nintendo switch  and 3ds and it's just revealed the 3ds  game called deep strange journey if that  name sounds familiar it's because this  is an updated version of strange journey  which hit the D s in 2009 this version  includes a new character named Alex a  new ending path new artwork and more  additional info is coming soon in  Japan's feminine so be sure to subscribe  to GameSpot to catch all the juicy  details Shin Megami Tensei deep strange  journey is due out this fall in Japan  but there's currently no word on whether  it or the SMT game plan for switch are  coming west if you need your RPG fix in  the meantime why not check out one of  our many gameplay clips from persona 5  [Music]  you  [Music]